what's the deal with airplane peanuts my
frustration with Cat Williams comes from
you keep pointing at Hollywood when do
you take responsibility for your actions
you had the shot you were set up to be
the star you didn't show up to work you
off promo shoots the the industry
doesn't mess with cat cuz he didn't show
up for the studio no Studios have ever
said that look at mydb it will show you
that no Studio has ever lost money with
me on the script at one point in time I
had seven shows on TV all at once so in
2012 I had to walk away Steve told you
that he stopped doing standup because he
had seven TV shows the only problem is
when he stopped standup he didn't have
those seven TV shows I auditioned for
Mighty Mike right you know so when I
went in there to audition I'm at the
toilet uh when when Cat Williams went to
use the bathroom that was that was
that's the line I had to use to audition
so they switched it up so like yeah I
can do this Santa Claus role but I
didn't know that cuz I did my role like
in 4 days 35 members of the cast and
crew have never brought up that Ricky
Smiley was going to play Money Mike no
one ever saw me put on a Santa Claus
suit we got a wardrobe department they
made a Santa Claus suit for me why that
wasn't in the bloopers and and here's
the other thing everything that money
Mike said Cat Williams wrote so what
Ricky Smiley say on his you can't say my
lines I wrote them that's how I already
already know that I'm going to be
funnier than you cat Williams just
caught out the entire comedy industry
during a rare podcast appearance on Club
Shay in order to set the record straight
about the real reasons behind his
long-standing beef with Kevin Hart Ricky
Smiley Steve Harvey and more as well as
exposing handfuls of comedians who've
sold their souls to the Hollywood Elites
in exchange for hundreds of millions of
dollars worth of movie roles and their
current level of aess celebrity Fame
during this 2hour and 46-minute
bombshell interview cat also spoke his
mind on a range of other topics such as
his life story leading up to becoming a
stand-up icon his friendship with Prince
and am Migos and even threw his two
cents in on Kim and Kanye what do you
expect the guy married a like what
oh
Lord I didn't mean it like that I mean
married her because she was one now he
didn't know he understood that he wanted
that but in this video we're just going
to focus on the comedy beef and not the
work ethic they talk about they tell you
work ethic where they do all these
movies I'm the hardest working man well
no everybody goes to work every day but
don't say I'll go to work all the time
everybody who works goes to work every
day shut up Shannon sharp has
interviewed dozens of famous comedians
on his show but according to Shannon
he's been trying to get Cat Williams in
the guest seat since 2022 the moment
that Cat Williams agreed however he
warned Shannon sharp that this interview
will not only break the internet but
Skyrocket Club Shay to a whole new level
which is exactly what happened the Cat
Williams interview is going to hit well
over 40 million views Shannon's YouTube
channel has gained close to 1 million
new subscribers in the last 4 days alone
and at this point most of the comedians
called out by Cat Williams have
responded in some way shape or form but
before we take a look at those responses
let's first hear a little more of
exactly what Cat Williams had to say
Cedric told you when you asked him did
you steal Cat Williams joke he said it
don't line up how it don't line up that
I did it on TV in 2018 you came to see
me at The Comedy Store do it 2019 and
then did it on the Kings of Comedy this
is a televised joke that Mark Curry
helped me punch up and get to the level
that it was the same Steve that went to
go watch Mark Curry do his whole sitcom
and then stole everything Mark Curry had
now Steve got a sitc count where he the
principal and he wear a suit then you
asked why you not a movie star I didn't
want to be a movie star that's the same
negro that hated on Bernie with this
same thing thing I didn't want to be a
movie star no you couldn't be a movie
star there are 30,000 new scripts in
Hollywood every year not one of them
asked for a country bumpkin black dude
that can't talk good over and look like
Mr Potato Head there ain't none you
would have to have a range I played a
lot of character 60 movie roles I'm not
playing Cat Williams in there for a
5-year period every single movie that
Kevin Hart did was a movie that had been
on my desk that I I had said was just
can we take some of this step and
fetchet out and then I can do it
like it don't need to be overtly
homosexual cuz I'm not homosexual right
it doesn't need that to be funny right
and and me saying that and them going oh
yeah no problem and then going to give
it to this other guy and having him do
it just like it was and acting like I'm
a bad person because I keep standing on
my standard you know what the number one
job of somebody that sold their soul in
Hollywood is what is to act like it
didn't happen they all do the same job
why do you think Gary Owen can't cross
over and he already whiteed and been in
comedy for 25 years if what I say ain't
the case this is how you end up with a
Michael blackon who's a real African
doing a fake African ACC okay this guy
is mad at me all I did was give him the
best advice of his life remember he was
wearing dirty dashiki and I told him he
need is to dress to be in the position
that he's trying to say that he's in and
if you're the African king of Comedy sir
there's actually comedians in Africa
doing comedy if you going to say that
you got to go to Africa and get a school
dude everybody got you you got to put in
some work and these guys they take my
advice they change their whole Persona
and and then they hate me for it this is
like Steve Harvey telling people he used
to be homeless that's my story that's
not his story Steve Harvey was never
homeless when he Mark Curry was touring
with him 25 years ago he was making
$3,000 a show in cash and doing five
shows a week they just tell the stories
this my thanks to my wife I'm where I am
you said that about the first wife you
forget that you told us it was her then
you went and married somebody else that
think like a man like what are you
talking about they just they think they
can rewrite history guy Tori did a
beautiful special about The Comedy Store
in Fat Tuesday where he said that Steve
and Cedric and Kevin Hart and Tiffany
hadish came through there and made all
lies steveen Cedric never performed at
The Comedy Store at all Tiffany was only
seen at the lab Factory in 15 years in
Hollywood no one in Hollywood has a
memory of going to a sold out Kevin Hart
show there being aign for him ever
getting a standing ovation at any Comedy
Club he already had his deals when he
got here have we heard of a comedian
that came to LA and in his first year in
La he had his own sitcom on network
television and had his own movie called
Soul Plane that he was leading no we've
never heard of that before that person
or since that person what do you think a
plant is Cat Williams won Cedric the
entertainers and haer Bush best best Los
Angeles comic award did you win that
award one Cat Williams is a simple yes
or no it's not a rhetorical question
it's a question that probably should
have been asked to cedre De Entertainer
I'm asking you I got you here though I
know I couldn't believe CED get asked
that question you still a D's joking to
give a award and then 10 years later you
don't know nothing about
it hey but I but I promise you this what
if he sees me again before he sees you
he'll be talking different when you see
it that's for certain that's the
difference that's what these Comics
understand is that I'm not doing nothing
for cloud I don't even recognize clout
but eventually the Lord is going to let
me and you be in one hallway Kevin
Harden went 25 5 years without ever
being in the same building with me at
the same time if I go in the building he
walk out you've never seen us in the
same building ever in 25 years it's like
that why why because I'm really the
product it's not what you think I am
never under the influence of anything
I'm always in my right mind that would
be like me being on Joe Rogan Joe don't
want me on there I need to be on Shannon
Joe Joe got six comedians that never
been funny he want to push
out but that's really how it is I'm so
sorry I'm competitive Kevin Hart was
quick to respond to cat's comments
ironically using this drama as a way to
advertise his new movie saying quote got
to get that anger up out you champ it's
honestly sad please enjoy my movie
trailer to my next film lift which will
be dropping on Netflix in 8 days there's
a moment in the trailer where they say
they really love you I now know she's
talking about cat Mark your Calendar's
world this one's special Michael blackon
had multiple responses first tweeting
I'm so confused I'm African with a fake
African accent my accent had me roasted
every day in school and in the comedy
clubs in America and I wish I could get
rid of it even my Philly accent is fake
I guess the only real thing about me is
my deak and then went on to list his top
10 black comedians alive putting Cat
Williams number four but clarifying that
we all have to agree he's not the same
cat from 2005 Tiffany hadish was next to
chime in saying I am not mad I just wish
he would get his facts right about me
dang I guess I will send him a reminder
text but are we sure that's Cat Williams
he looks a lot like Charleston white
Gary Owen quote tweeted someone asking
for clarification saying I'm not sure if
cat was giving me respect or saying I'm
not and finally Joe Rogan quote
tweeted the clip of cat calling out his
show and said I love cat he's one of my
favorite comics and I'd love to have him
on we talk about him all the time if
he's down I'll make it happen and a few
comedians who are commonly on the Joe
Rogan Experience also reacted to being
called out by association such as
Giannis papus who said I know you ain't
talking about me cat I'll show you a
dress Joe Liss said well maybe I've
never been funny on the show but I've
had my moments on stage by myself and
Mark Norman who said Cat Williams just
dropped the black Epstein Client List
ever since this episode started going
viral there's been people calling what
Cat Williams did a publicity stunt
claiming that nobody was talking about
cat a few months ago but now he's the
toast of the town after saying a few
inflammatory statements truth don't need
motivation I'm just saying I can't let
these dudes lie Cedric sitting here
telling you why he ain't a movie star he
over here look like a walrus you didn't
say nothing he can't even get his arms
off his stomach sitting over here why
I'm not a movie what he never wrote
anything remember when Cedric the
Entertainer starts he's supposed to be
singing dancing and telling jokes that's
why he's called the Entertainer we found
out he can't sing can't dance and
doesn't write jokes he did four comedy
specials they're so bad Shannon they're
not available on Netflix or tub after
watching the entire 3-hour podcast it's
hard to say Cat Williams doesn't sound
believable especially because outside of
Joe Rogan none of the responses so far
even address the detailed stories that
Cat Williams laid out for us on Club
Shay if he truly isn't telling the truth
I don't see why any of these comedians
who all have huge platforms of their own
haven't come out with any actual facts
to prove cat wrong although it is
understandable to not want to engage
directly with cat if these are lies and
escalate this conflict even further but
at this point 35 million people have
watched this podcast not to mention the
hundreds of other clips that have
already been posted so you'd think
clearing this up would be a top priority
for all these Comedians and it will be
interesting to see if any more comedians
respond and hopefully Cat Williams even
takes Joe Rogan up on the offer to have
him on the podcast all of this seems
like the type of topic Joe Rogan would
love to go super deep into if cat
doesn't go on JRE it might be years
before we hear from him again Joe got
six comedians that never been funny he
want to push
out but that's really how it is it's
pretty funny the only laughs I got was
making fun of my own
self like yeah you do
suck I was like guys you don't know I'm
actually pretty good in the white
Community but guest spots from last week
The Joe Rogan Experience had on Taylor
Sheridan two bears one cave was Tom and
Jessica Kon kill Tony this week was with
Kurt Fox YH and we might be drunk did
not have guests are you garbage spoke
with ch Dina Matt and Shane secret
podcast had on James Donald Forbes mccan
taste buds battled baked potato vers
potato salad Brad Williams was a guest
on Whiskey Ginger hey babe posted a best
of 2023 recap as did Tiger belly and bad
friends had on Bobby's M on the way here
we saw an escort while walking and I
said hey that looks like a prostitute
and we had a good laugh right remember
that
Moa
no shut up shut shut up Bora what he say
he this is what he said right this is
good for our audience when you were
walking
in this past weekend with theovon talked
with Sean Strickland Tom sagoro was on
the brand new Wayback podcast hosted by
Ryan sickler the blocks podcast set on
Jimmy Carr Being Ian with Jordan
welcomed Louie Katz Sarah Sherman and
Jack Ben singer visited stav's World
Giannis papus went on Soder and colum
Terrell and Ryan long were on the Legion
of skanks as far as new standup specials
are either out right now or coming out
soon Ricky Jas Armageddon and Dave
Chappelle the dreamer both are out on
Netflix Paul Alia's debut special
Detroit Player is available right now on
mint comedy.com with promo code Paul Sam
Talent the Toads morale is on Matt and
Shane secret YouTube page also out on
YouTube is Taylor Williamson live at The
Comedy Store and Ian bag vers the
government and a few projects are going
to be coming out soon Eric Andre live
near Broadway is coming out on January
18th then Dusty slay's debut Netflix
special work man comes out on January
23rd followed by Taylor Tomlinson have
it all which premieres globally on
Netflix February 13th 2024 if this is
your first time visiting this Channel
and you're wondering what this video is
all about welcome to the joke World
comedy news update bringing you all the
biggest news in the comedy world every
single week thank you for watching and
be sure to subscribe right now if you
want to stay in the comedy Loop also
feel free to check out some more videos
on this channel related to all your
favorite comedians including the
funniest moments from last month on the
end screen right after this
P joke
world that's it J
world and the world is
wld that's a great uh YouTube channel
joke World check it out